[Music]
what did y'all think about jeremy lin
uh snitching on the [ __ ]
calling him corona fire
that [ __ ] is so funny he said how are
you not gonna call him chrono buyers bro
yeah how are you not like if i know
you're greek and we're hooping i'm
calling you canados
yeah yeah right 100 percent you're a
kanaidos bro yeah you see how he's
backing the paint that's how he used to
be when he was learning how to paint
or whatever they did what if we were
greeks painters sculptors
uh yeah but yeah they painted sculpture
but that was the thing like
you know i mean he just minimized it
what did you guys do you got i don't
know started democracy republics
[ __ ] architecture algebra it's all
[ __ ] up
like i hate how people act like they
invented math bro like people didn't
know what the [ __ ] [ __ ] was before you
that's it you think they were just
looking at things going i don't know how
much is on this table
how many goats do you got i don't know
we haven't thanked the numbers yet
i really don't know should we do a trade
you're going for my pelicans
how can we ever know about that it'd be
impossible we're the greeks still in bed
numbers it's
the greeks are so [ __ ] arrogant to
think they're the only people that could
think of
counting things we are the we stole it
from the egyptians we are the elvis
of cultures oh yeah we stole it from the
egyptians
and egyptians they're the only ones that
learned how to count [ __ ] i think it's
just them we invented triangles
shut up before that it's aliens or
something
anyway how did we get to this i don't
remember no jeremiah oh yeah jeremy lin
yeah so jeremy lin's out there getting
called coronavirus on the court right
and he's not even in the nba of course
you can get called coronavirus if you're
in the g league
there's a bunch of guys that are dying
to make a team right they're making 30
a year barely feed their families maybe
it was a compliment like yo you're about
to invade the league you're about to
really take over [ __ ]
the sun yeah yeah
yeah lockdown
you can change the yeah of history yeah
and honestly defending him makes you out
of breath
yeah you feel like you guys have grown
about chase and jeremy lynn around the
corner
yo he never had he never had a problem
being called insanity
yeah right some people might say that
that's a little insensitive to mental
health yeah he's a veteran now instead
of a climate veteran you just call him a
long-hauler you know
i didn't understand what that was corona
long-haulers no
oh [ __ ] joke actually yeah that's good
i thought you were talking like truckers
yeah yeah yeah long haul you're on a
long night that's right you can test
positive for a while
[Laughter]
no but that's true like isn't it some
bitch-ass [ __ ] there's some real
bitch-ass [ __ ] like
you're playing basketball almost
everything's on the table
like you can't be there's no like m-word
that kind of stuff but like
kind of racist [ __ ] goes on a court
especially
yes white boy luca got called that [ __ ]
ass white boy and i can't believe we had
a whole [ __ ] apology about that [ __ ]
the nba didn't make him do [ __ ]
especially if black people are the
ones saying it they deserve they have a
you have they have like diplomatic
immunity white guy calling him corona
they got diplomatic immunity black
people have diplomatic community like
diplomats with crime like if you're
going to call someone a racial certainly
black you can do it yeah
she's got diplomatic community no the
diplomats now are getting anally fisted
by the chinese yeah
but it's still completely illegal
nukem nukes click click
boom i like it i read jeremy lin's
statement and a lot of the [ __ ] he was
like we're not gonna handle
stand for this anymore i thought it
would be like there's one of you
yeah there's one asian like
asian [ __ ] in america in general yeah
and most of it i was like
this is a big deal to you it's like the
way they're represented in movies or
some [ __ ] like that it's like bruh
talk about the hate crimes i'm with you
yeah talk about treating chinese
americans
poorly because of the virus all right
cool and that's [ __ ] up
it's you want you can't treat chinese
americans poorly because of the virus
you can't obviously do not
you know any acts of violence against
chinese americans is absolutely
disgusting
but we're going to call you chronovirus
if we're your friend
you can't tell me i can't be racist with
my friends what's the point of
friendship
what's the point of friendship if i
can't call my asian friend coronavirus
that's a good point
i've probably been calling ronnie chain
coronavirus for about six months
ever since coronavirus came around i'm
like ronnie why would you bring this
here
it's like yo man you helped me move you
were there for me when mom died but yo
we really friends cause you never called
me corona fire
you can't even trust it if your white
friend hasn't called you coronavirus yet
can you trust him he's hiding something
he's hiding something yeah
come on bro just because he don't have
any snapbacks on the black dudes that's
what it is
uh because like he can't say anything
well he could get dreadlocks
remember when he got his little
dreadlocks
yeah kenyon martin's dumbass called him
out yeah he's like that's cultural
appropriation and then jeremy was like
dude you have eight
characters on your head yeah i'm just
saying it seems like
like some soft and then he goes i'm not
gonna snitch i'm not gonna say the exact
person because
ruining that person's life wouldn't be
good so what are you saying this for
just like some victimhood [ __ ] that's
all it is
yeah it's it's you that was the
beginning of it i think
those yeah it's like isn't it isn't that
a celebration of the culture if you're
doing something
especially if you're asian i bet black
people call him coronavirus it's a term
of endearment on the basket yeah
wait is he mad because of that or is he
mad because it's for a disc bro
like [ __ ] hits yeah right but corona
violet he's already back on defense
you